(quirky music)
- Oh good, you're home.
Let us proceed.
- Proceed?
Babe, I had a really long day.
Can I just change into
my eight o'clock pants?
- If you have a seat please.
There's a mystery afoot.
- Why are you speaking
in a British accent?
- I'm sure you're wondering why
I've summoned you here today?
- I live here.
- Look, I'm just trying to do a thing OK,
can you go and have a seat?
Just wanna do, just a thing.
- Oh my god, I did not fake it.
- Exhibit A.
I rinsed this bowl, I did not wash it.
- OK.
- When you found it later
that night, you said you were,
"Fine with it."
When in fact you were not fine.
- It literally takes one
extra second to just lean down
and put it in the dishwasher.
It takes longer to do
whatever it is that you do.
- So you admit it?
Sorry, I'm really excited right now.
- Yeah.
- Exhibit B.
You have four separate alarms do you not?
- OK, this is like, sort of ridiculous.
- Answer the question!
- Yep, I have four separate alarms.
- And when our smoldering
passions have ignited in the past
you used to set your alarm
for the latest possible time.
- Can you not say, "Smoldering passions."
- What time did your alarm
go off this morning Lela?
- Lila.
6:15.
- The earliest time.
- Yeah.
- The evidence is stacking
up against you my dear.
- OK, I'm gonna go change
outta my work clothes--
- And finally exhibit C, the
most damning of them all.
- Symptoms?
Babe, how long did it
take you to make that?
- I called out sick from work.
If you would please turn your
attention to the bar graph
you will notice that
the, "Moaning," column is
unusually high, while the, "Eye closing,"
and the, "Back arching,"
is, is weirdly low.
- I'm sorry, what does that prove?
- Simply that in the
absence of a true orgasm,
you oversold the moan.
You see what I did there?
- Yeah, you dropped the--
- I dropped the remote that's right.
So?
- OK, you're right.
- I knew it.
- I just really stress out, and
I had that big meeting today
so, I promise I won't do it again.
- OK, it was just a one-time thing right?
Whoa, babe, babe, babe.
It was just a one-time thing right?
- Of course.
I mean you can tell if
I'm faking it, right?
Hmmhmm.